je cite la mariée annonce la fin du
défilé et l'on comprend alors la raison
de la présence de robert altman et de
anouk aimée nous sommes sur le point de
commencer un film
il s'intitulera prêt-à-porter on
commence à sonner le plan et on termine
en ils ont fermé
big lots roberto
on s'attend pas non plus à prendre
mais pourquoi avoir choisi mois avant
qu'ils ferment se mériter mansonnienne
régisseur de via rail
elle sera mon guide dans sera mon guide
dans ce monde
à partir du moment où j'ai accès
résultat les qu'il a vu a dit l'arrêt
il a compris entre mille a compris la
bulle de travail
chanut
chaque mieux faire chacun leur île
la distribution brillante et audacieuse
dans l'amour et dans l'euro elle sonia
ils auront de la can j'ai regardé ma
gare au loup vers la diplomatie chez
milot l'immobilier vient de glisse et
bientôt la nudité concrètement la marque
face à la marée noire
evènement à dissimuler
gageons qu'il saura les joindre et le
moral de la mort est le membre de la
mode dans toutes ses lignes